you might know me from tech talk of
course we know charlie demilio from tick
tock but we're about to learn a whole
lot more
now that the entire demelio fam has made
it to hulu
it's definitely different than i thought
it was going to be on monday the
streaming service dropped the trailer
for the family's new series
the demilio show giving us an inside
look at what it's really like to be
charlie and dixie demilio
charlie my sister
we are best friends other days we can't
even look
at each other dixie she's
very protective over me it seems like
we'll also be getting a sneak peek
inside their professional lives
with charlie working on her dance career
and dixie chasing her musical dreams one
two go three go turn yeah
and when it comes to making their goals
a reality both tick-tock stars have been
crushing it
last year charlie's dance moves made her
the most followed person on tick-tock
with now over 100 million followers it's
crazy to think that this is real life
while dixie has been creating viral hits
with big names like wiz khalifa and
black bear
[Music]
however the demilio show won't be all
glitz and glam
earlier this month charlie and dixie
exclusively revealed to et that their
reality series will
show it all the good the bad and
everything in between
i was talking to your dad before and he
was like i kind of thought they would be
up in my face with the cameras but it's
very chill so how has it been filming so
far and are you ready to be a reality
television family
um it's it's definitely different than i
thought it was going to be just
because i'll be doing like normal things
or things that i think is normal and
they'll be videoing and i'm like
how could they make this interesting
like i feel like i feel like this is so
boring
but then we got to watch a few little
previews of the episodes and and it's
really cool to see
our lives being portrayed in
a really honest way i mean it shows the
ups and the downs and the things that we
get to do every day no one really gets
to see the business side like
what was behind making this and now
people are and i think that that's so
exciting to be able to share with
everyone
and aside from being on tick tock
dancing singing and now having a reality
show
charlie and dixie are pursuing another
exciting venture
as fashion designers the two are
partnering with hollister for their new
clothing line
social tourists
let's unpack this life together so
social tourist
is obviously very fitting to us because
we do social media
but it's also about self-discovery and
finding who you are because we're all a
tourist to something and we can all try
new things and really
meet new people and figure out our
self-identity and i feel like that's
really what it's about and that's why
it's so exciting it's all about everyone